poverty is rampant in Istanbul Kurdish
quarter there are few jobs and prospects
for the future a bleak election penance
has suspended over the street promoting
the Kurdish people's democratic party
the HDP since jun 2014 when the HDP
first one seats in the turkish
parliament the Kurds in Istanbul have
felt uneasy like this grocer who is
afraid for his business Toby Kiwis
unless I Kenyans are records no longer
feel safe I know there have been attacks
on chops not on me personally but I've
heard about them I'm mistrustful I hope
things don't stay like this I hope we
have peace again soon for a while there
were a few problems between Turks and
Kurds but since the conflict started up
again I'm really worried and Schillinger
today many young western-oriented Turks
are asking themselves where is turkey
headed they regard turkey as part of
Europe entrepreneur aishah as gunas is a
good example two years ago she founded
her own company designing handbags a
local craftsman produces them right now
she's working on the new designs for her
winter collection she wants to sell them
not only at home but also in Europe the
United States and Australia but she
doesn't feel she can make long-range
plans everything is very uncertain at
the moment in Turkey and we don't we
cannot see the prologue project future
for ourselves and the environment is
very tense and like it's very hard to
imagine myself what's going to happen in
five years the instability of turkeys is
very
shifting all the time the handbag
designer is also concerned about the
week turkish lira she has had to raise
the price of her handmade accessories
because the leather and fabric she buys
from abroad are increasingly expensive
that's a problem for many Turkish
manufacturers Turkey's economy has been
booming in recent years despite the
world financial crisis the government
Foster's young startups with special
programs that help them access money
from investors but political stability
is at the top of the wish list for many
young company founders like our surf
owner who hopes his new hotel service
will get a share of the tourism business
like two years ago we had all these
protests going on at the gezi Park so it
affected almost fifty five percent of
all the entire reservations coming to
Turkey we had so many cancellations by
the time so I really never want to
experience the same thing again the head
of the startup program she damn Doraemon
hopes the elections coming on Sunday
will calm things down sure we are not
happy to see such atmosphere in our
country but it's it's not a problem at
all because we know that there will be a
solution soon Turkey's economy can
continue to grow only if the political
system secures the framework for it
everyone hopes there will be a new
chance for that after the elections